okay so Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness is about to hit Cinemas
worldwide this week and we have a ton of
new trailer and TV spots promoting the
film filled with Easter eggs cameos and
hidden details this is gonna be our last
video going over the film before we get
to see it on Thursday come Friday I'll
be sat annoyed at myself for over
analyzing another Marvel movie so that
it ruined everything and that's why I'm
giving you this one chance this one
chance Punk to be a better man than me
so if you don't want spoilers then get
out of here now I cannot do a memory
spell on you but chances are you're
addicted to the spoilers like your Uncle
Kevin you son of a [ __ ] I love you now
without the way thank you for clicking
this let's get into the Multiverse of
Madness
Stephen Strange
[Music]
the Illuminati will see you now
you can travel a Multiverse
dismay rule number one a multiversal
travel
you don't know anything
[Music]
smart kids
what's rule number two
foreign
[Music]
okay so the first TV spot I want to talk
about reveals some major cameos and also
confirms versions of the characters that
we were expecting to see in the movie
the first one I want to go over is Tom
Cruise as Superior Iron Man psych you
dummy I'll never forget when I told you
punks that Lashana Lynch was Captain
Marvel and you guys said it was Tom
Cruise yes you idiot what do you mean I
spent nine weeks telling you Mephisto
was gonna be in one division cut that
cut that now anyway we now have it
pretty much fully confirmed that this is
Lashana Lynch as a member of the
Illuminati we know from one division
that she was also a high-ranking member
of Sword before she sadly passed away
during the five years between the snap
and the blip however alternate universes
contain alternate versions of her and it
looks like she's getting Captain
Marvel's Powers instead of Carol Danvers
the pair of course about Pilots down at
Project Pegasus and if you cast your
mind back to Captain Marvel then you
might remember that they were both
called to the base during the Tesseract
test flight Carol took a shortcut so she
got there earlier and she volunteered to
fly the plane what if let's say she
didn't do that then it's highly possible
that Maria arrived there before her and
ended up in the cockpit thus she would
get captain Marvel's Powers but whereas
Carol decided to remain out in the
Galaxy Maria might have returned to
Earth and stayed there in order to be
with her daughter see bloody great
theories aren't they now someone else
who's a good example of what if is
Captain Carter who we also get a look at
in the new TV spot if you've been
watching our videos then you'll know we
pointed out that her Shield was on the
poster but it's nice to actually see her
in action when I say we pointed out yet
I don't just mean me by the way yeah so
sorry if it sounds like only I find
these Easter eggs I know you guys are
better at this than I am anyway in it we
see her going toe-to-toe with one day in
the Illuminati headquarters base and it
looks like quite a good Showdown
interestingly she's actually wearing a
jet pack which we see fire up at one
point Captain Carter didn't really have
one of these and my guess is that it's
been developed by either the person
behind the old Trump Bots or someone
else potentially a Mr Fantastic now huge
shout out to a chatterbox film for
pointing out that you can potentially
even see Mr Fantastic on the floor next
to Captain Corey if you look closely at
the ground there's this weird jumble of
black and blue which looks exactly like
how he looks when he gets torn apart
kinda feel like he might be one of the
main members of the Illuminati and that
he may have helped to develop the Ultron
Bots now I'm gonna let you guys off yeah
I'm gonna be nice I'm gonna let you off
for saying it was Tom Cruise's Iron Man
because when we look at the Ultron Bots
they actually tie into the comics quite
a lot Superior Iron Man was sort of a
bad Tony Stark and this entire reality
seems like it's very much what would
have happened had the Ultron initiative
been a success sadly in our reality
Ultron took one look at the internet and
was like nah these Folks Gotta Go
however this one looks like a waste
trick to timeline and who knows Tony
Stark might have bought Twitter instead
of Elon Musk so the Ultron Bots would
have been developed as a standard and
therefore they could kind of use this
technology to give Captain Carter a jet
pack you also get a brand new statue in
the base that shows a sort of warrior
woman a Wonder woman if you will with
content I might get to cut it cut it and
it's difficult to tell who this is from
just the legs and I don't actually
recognize them as being a typical
character from the greater Marvel
Universe I even asked on Twitter nobody
had an idea so it could be a black widow
a captain Carter or potentially one of
the X-Men which takes us to our next
point and the trailer also gave us a
much better look at Patrick Stewart and
by that I mean his hand I love how
they're like slowly teasing out
Professor X by showing us his shoulder
and then his hands like we didn't get
Professor X in seven films we know what
you look like mate there's no point
hiding it now it would be hilarious if
this was a bait and switch and it was
actually James McAvoy but I'd digress
anyway X gon' give it here in this movie
in his classic yellow flooding chair in
all of the X-Men films outside of days
of future past the guy just had one with
standard Wheels though they did have a
cool little X symbol on the side of them
however much in the same way that
Captain Carter has some new tech exters
too now the Captain Marvel suit also
looks way more silver than what we've
typically had before and this makes me
think it's more in line with the Ultron
box that we are going to be getting now
X's chair of course Paul's from the 90s
fox cartoon and he also has the green
suit to go along with it absolutely love
this and I'm actually so happy that
we're getting classic versions at Disney
plus day we had the announcement that
we're getting an X-Men 97 cartoon which
could potentially even tell the origin
story for this video station much like
how what if kinda fell in what happened
to Captain Carter now whether this
version we see in the film is the same
one from the show we don't know but I do
kinda doubt it episode 9 ended with her
working alongside Black Widow to
discover Steve Rogers in storage which I
kind of think is a story they'll carry
on in season two of the show so I think
this will just be a variant of Carter
rather than the one that we've already
met it looks like the illuminaria
throwing all I have at wonder and it
makes me wonder who's gonna win just
kidding yeah Wanda's gonna kill them all
isn't she now we've got that shot of her
carrying an Ultron head along with her
and also the one where she's covered in
blood or oil kinda thinks she's just
gonna murder them all making for the
third Marvel movie where Professor Rex
has died now I kind of want to put a
question to you guys whilst we go
through the rest of the video say one
that does kill all of the Illuminati
doesn't make it a redeemable can she
ever go back to being a good guy after
murdering lots of Heroes in one Universe
let me know in the comments below anyway
Professor X says see what kind of doctor
strange you are making me think they've
had run-ins with him in the past in the
trailer we meet an evil version of the
character and coupled with the one from
what if shows how dangerous the
character can be mordo of course said
he's a massive threat and both destroy
their own realities by the looks of it
so it makes sense that the Illuminati
would handcuff any version that they
come across and investigate the kind of
character they are first Professor X
being able to read people's minds would
be a big help and thus he could
determine if he's good or bad now I
think the division of strange was also
on the Illuminati and this is why we see
a statue firm in the trailer this looks
like Defender strange who appears to die
after being killed by the big ribbon
monster that strings of America Chavez
this version has scars on his face as he
hurdles through the air and if we look
at the zombie version that appears this
guy also has the same markings now we
know from the trailers that Wong asks
what the hell's going on with him and
it's likely that the MCU version ends up
possessing this one until this TV spot
we also got one where strange flies
through the Multiverse us alongside
America throughout this we hear the pair
screaming as they travel through each
Dimension and this Alters the way they
sound bearing that in mind let's look at
the clip
you okay so you have the paint Dimension
which massively changes their Scream and
also the 1920s looking cartoon one which
even changes to a laugh and the first
block Dimension looks like they're
giving nods to the famous House of M
cover but wonders Phase 10 in the blocks
as she altered reality there's next the
paint World which looks like it's from
the major laser lighted up video next is
the Noir universe that sort of has the
characteristics of a cartoon there's
classic cars a blimp and it has a serpia
tone over the top of it making it look
slightly black and white though Sony is
holding their Spider-Man characters as
closely as they can I'd love it if it
was revealed that this is actually
Spider-Man was universe and I think that
would be such a cool way to kind of tie
this all together huge shout outs to
emergency awesome for pawning either the
next universe is the cree Empire in
which they took over Earth the cree were
the same species that Captain Marvel
joined so who knows in this Dimension
she might have even helped them we
travel into another futuristic almost
Blade Runner looking universe and this
could potentially be Spider-Man 2099
following this is a slightly further in
the future universe that reminds me a
lot of Mirror's Edge from here we get a
lava Planet possibly taken over by certa
or someone else could even be one where
the celestial tear mod wasn't stopped by
the eternals and this is why the planet
is fully destroyed lastly we see them
Landing in New York full of lush green
Plantation and this can also be seen on
the buildings next to the defender
strange statue so guessing that this is
the Illuminati universe as well but we
will of course see now there was another
teaser dropped where strange in America
also traveled through portals and in
this we could catch the Living Tribunal
this is a gigantic judge character from
the comics whose head also appeared in
Loki episode 5. though it's a
split-second shot it's awesome seeing
the tribunal amongst the universes and
it kind of teases that he could end up
showing up at some point down the line
now we also got two fight scenes of the
battle in New York between the wizards
and gargantos
foreign
[Music]
all right
oh my God
[Applause]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
you chill out to Twitter for pointing
out that you get this one extra ring by
strange over and over Sam Raimi is known
for doing stuff like this in his movies
and it's a great tradition to constantly
have extras doing Wild Things in the
background no strange makes the
invisible monster appear which makes me
think it might have the same magic place
in it as the jackals do in Moonlight
this scene also continues the habit of
having buses completely empty in the MCU
and we also get some great mirror
Dimension effects on it now this is
clearly just after America and you can
catch it even reaching out to her with
its seven tentacle a strange whisks are
away on the back of his cape now if you
look closely you can also see what looks
like runes on the tentacles making me
think that this is summoned by a spell
there are rumors that one there is the
one controlling these monsters in order
to get America so that she can absorb
her powers and then travel across the
Multiverse this will give her the power
to go where her kids are and it does
make sense when we look at the rest of
the film you can also catch a pizza
parlor called Mancini's Pizzeria which
is likely another Don Mancini a great
person that's a very influential in
horror movies who's also a close friend
of Sam Raimi absolutely love this double
team and it's great seeing Wong use
physical weapons along with his magic
really can't wait until the movie
releases and this is our last video on
the film before we go see it and
obviously love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we are on a competition right now
giving away three copies of Spider-Man
now a home on the 15th of May and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the teasers you pick the comments at
random and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out
Moonlight theories before we get into
the finale that's coming up on Wednesday
linked on screen right now get the hell
out of here you punk and don't come back
also thanks for thanks for getting us to
900 000 subscribers really appreciate it
and I love you I didn't mean to call you
punk you're you're a nice person you
obviously are because you support me and
I appreciate that you take care of
yourself peace